we right now before maybe you didn't
catch it it's this long pair of
fractions okay we should have y minus y
1 X minus X 1 and then the fraction on
the right hand side is actually very
very similar like that
there's your gradient okay what I want
you to know is I'm going to pour that
let you haven't got this yourself you've
got all the information that needs to be
substituted into here okay when you do
that it's going to be a bit of a remodel
okay lots of numbers flying everywhere I
want you to simplify it until you can
get it into that form you mentioned
before y equals MX plus B can you please
do two things number one substitute your
number there you're welcome to your
calculator because they're gross numbers
and once you substitute rearranged until
you get to this form okay can you do
that I'll give you three or four minutes
to have a go so just to repeat you're
substituting the points into here and
then you're rearranging everything so
that it's in a nice form that's neat and
we can graph a message okay
have a go let's have a look now you tell
me does this check out right you can see
right at the top I just quoted this 2
point formula and then I've noticed okay
what my x1 y1 r1a x2 y2 are and I've
just substituted in then you can see a
lot of numbers simplify out right you've
got the numerator and denominator on the
right hand side they're both simplified
and you get a fraction that you can also
simplify and then you come to something
like this this is where I ended okay
who's got the answer
yes and up yes okay it has been all we
I'll come to that in a second the short
answer is at the moment no yeah I don't
I have a see other way around yeah
don't want any - some people do i oh
great okay that's a good question so and
in seden I did do this before and I
think I did a different order so what's
what's happened okay what Ellen is
talking about is tell me if I've got
this right
earng she's Richard this why - 180 on X
minus twenty six point five yes equals
150 to take 180 is that right okay now
here's what's really yeah with that
right now is this really cool about this
and I pointed this out back when we did
it but I haven't looked at it since the
to my formula takes the next old y1 and
x2 y2 doesn't matter which one is one
which ones - it's a note you will still
find an equation that goes through both
of those points and you can actually see
you're working should pan out to exactly
the same thing even if your numbers are
all somewhat rearranged okay so two
point Bobby are a bit like a distance
formula the midpoint formula you can
switch things around and you still get
the same result which is kind of nice
okay so the reason why I put it here at
the bottom as a decimal is just so that
I can actually put this as a graph onto
a piece of software that will graph this
for me
okay that's one of the reasons why your
graph was different to mine okay so
here's the data i engraft before this is
a piece of software called desmos and I
think I've shown it what supplies before
I didn't want you guys to see this first
because it sort of takes out the
language that you need to practice but
you're welcome for some of these later
questions to have to go with it
there's all my data you say that all my
heights ends what was it the radius that
visible oh yeah so now I'm going to
write in the equation can you help me
remember it's y equals 4 I think I read
four point six six that's the gradient X
and then I think it was plus okay so let
me just want you to color that a bit
better yeah all right so we've actually
looked that we've judged it based on our
eye and then we come out with this
equation
and you can actually get software which
will and I've done verify the fact
you've got an equation that really does
fit the data weddings okay so you've got
an equation now let me finish I'll ask
you to do questions one two four and six
where like 90 percent three question one
so let's finish it together the rest of
question one says you've done Part A and
B so we're going to do Part C use your
equation to find the height of a female
whose radius is 25 centimeters long okay
let's have a look at your line of best
fit okay
can you go to your graph right and I
want you to find where you put 25 on the
horizontal axis
why am I looking at the horizontal axis
look what's your what's your horizontal
axis about you it's about the radius and
they say imagine if you've got the woman
who has a radius of 25 centimeters so
what I'm going to do it I'd like you to
do the same on your graph is get your
ruler out and go up from 25 up onto your
line of benefit and you'll have a point
up there right you see that let me just
highlight it a little more clearly once
there it is once you've got up to your
later best sphere where are you going to
go from there so the across to the left
because over there what do you have on
the vertical axis that's that that's the
height you're trying to predict remember
I said before you're trying to use this
information to predict things about
people don't know okay what do you read
that as 173 172 issue I'm happy I know
those because remember this is a line of
etiquette that you've done by eye okay
now this is a really important bit can
you look up this pressure through just
done has a name it's called and I'd love
you to write it down
it's called interpolation what that
means is you're making a prediction
you don't have you don't have anyone who
has a radius of 25 centimeters you're
just sort of getting predicting estimate
it's called an interpolation because 25
centimeters is inside your data right
when I say inside I mean look at the
person with the smallest radius or the
small trees
20 the 20 22 or something something like
that a twenty point four what's the
largest radius you've got look across
twenty six point twenty three six point
no 36.2 or something with that yeah so
six point two so the twenty five is
within that range so interpolation is
within your data range okay that
interpolation but if you have a look at
the last part of this question he says
if the radius is twenty seven
centimeters twenty seven
so now come back to your graph 27th
groups my graph doesn't even go to 27 do
you notice that
look 27 is over here and my graph does
again so your graph like better than one
so you're going to have to go up from 27
and you might need to extend your graph
that's what I would need to do I'm gonna
have to drop my grandpa little bit
further like that what color haven't I
used yeah all right great
like can you see that line so what I've
done is I've gone down to 27 over here
on your right hand side right and you
read up to the top and I guess we'd say
that's something like 182 depends on
your web right now notice please
previously we were interpolating we're
looking inside the data twenty-seven is
not inside the data is outside so we
don't call this interpolating we call
this extrapolating have you heard that
word before yeah extrapolating so both
of these things are predictions based on
our line of best fit and interpolation
is inside your data like this guy
and extrapolation is outside your data
well that's it right so I didn't mean
for that to be anyway bit for it okay so
what have we done maybe review line of
best in Troy dollar once you've got your
data what do you do next what's your
second step you're going to be you're
going to need this right and you're
going to have to you're gonna have to
sort of look and wave it around until
you're happy and then you're going to
draw how do you know if you're happy
what criteria do you use maybe we want
to try to get lots of points and then
above and below you roughly what the
same roughly okay once you've drawn it
then what do you do look at my blue
things what what I do that you're
looking for two points that are on your
life yeah the wall process that's a
statistical of the standing is really
traditional well right before I see
pressure once you got your two points
what do you do this to put information
no no no what do you do with your two
pointless you're going to need to find
the equation that lies right and then
you'll often get asked a question okay
and then lastly you can use your line of
best fit to make predictions about
things that you don't otherwise have
measurements for okay yeah question is
it's in the term will we get extra time
perfect so if you if this is a test then
there's obviously a time consuming
process you wouldn't mind a have for
example we have data provided to you
like you have a scatterplot and it would
say hey now clásico do this part right
or alternatively we say vector
scatterplot you draw the Y but then we
won't ask to it first because it's time
okay but this is a really important
skill to social skill